i did it like i did the chips yeah where
i kind of took a bite
at least you didn't have to be called
out this time you i know you're best
friends i ain't mine in one bite and
people were leaving that comment too
like cat didn't finish or was like i
promised you you were trying to say you
didn't fit yeah i was sitting right next
to her hold on let me let me do this
yeah get that three two one
[Music]
you're so funny uh
um
oh we can go
oh
um
meatball my dad told me uh that he [ __ ]
with you heavy
yeah and he also told me to uh
stop picking on you yeah so wait does
that mean i'm invited to the barbecue
since your dad likes me well i mean he's
a vegan but yeah oh your dad's vegan too
yeah yeah corn
yeah you could go i mean you can come to
the vegan barbecue
all right i'm down i'm down real quick
what's at a vegan barbecue though i
don't know i've never been to one corn
corn just corn corn jimmy crack corn and
i don't care democrat are you saying
that uh your dad was one of the 107 000
people that watched the first episode of
cats oh yeah yeah yeah dude
my dad's dope man he [ __ ] with like all
the things i do you know he's very
supportive and loves like you know being
especially because you know it's only
been like five years of us like knowing
each other so he's like super supportive
and very involved in my life in which
i'm like i don't need you to throw a
ball with me dawg i got this you know
what i'm saying but it's cool though you
know what i mean like it it actually
like does feel good but he doesn't like
it but he did say uh he [ __ ] with
meatball heavy and i don't know why i
was gonna say what's he like the most
about him i know right yeah yeah i i
gotta ask for that see what he is see
what it is that he likes about you yeah
i i'm dying
it's been a while i've been deprived
he said man leave me below man
that's how my dad talks i love you dad
we have to we should have him be be a
guest on uh yeah
yeah he was on king listening before
yeah
yeah he'll come on cat yeah he'll take a
la trip i mean like i said he vacations
in compton but
you know he can make a pissed off he'll
yeah he'll take a drive up to calabasas
[Laughter]
that episode that we had on it was a it
was a patreon episode of king and this
thing which all those were like
we put like the most fun stuff on those
patreon episodes and like they were the
fewest scene like when we did like that
was in the episode when we had uh
brendan's brother and theo's brother and
we yeah it was like a family yeah they
did like a family feud right oh they're
like
but they're with their brothers
no that's [ __ ] dope it's tight doing
this [ __ ] man i'm on my third one today
it seems like every time we do this part
i'm on my third one yeah this is always
the third pod for always the third part
for me but i got exciting news everybody
else i told that we have a special
announcement i didn't even tell you that
so you didn't get the anxiety of what
what could be the special i've been
anxious but uh we're not coming here for
free anymore
we have secured our first sponsor can
you uh reach under that uh under under
the couch on the couch yeah basically oh
bro i took that the wrong way i was like
damn we got to pay the beat
i was like
brendan's charging us now okay you say
anxiety yeah
times are stopped so you got to rent
this studio yeah
okay for
yeah yeah so you're familiar with this
uh magic magic mind is our first sponsor
thank you magic mind thank you magic mom
uh and uh i'll be i'll bleep this out
but they committed uh for
but as part of the commitment we all
have to take and we all get to take
take one home take no take it right now
[Laughter]
how much you take the entire thing the
entire thing is now and everybody
even if you don't like you like it
caffeine
it's 30 milligrams which is nothing it's
a gum with 12 other natural ingredients
echinacea
yeah can chipotle take mine
huh no you have to
you get to take this honestly meatball
you need this more than anyone it's it's
it's a focused drink you take it once
daily place your adderall with magic
i know being right that's where you move
this part out i get terrified of taking
anything so just let me know i'm going
to be okay you were this 1000 so it's
like it's like doing chappelle this is
this is tea this is a green tea
green tea
it's going to be fine
honestly it's it's like it's matcha it's
tea this is my chicken okay
still muting uh what's stronger coffee
or this coffee coffee coffee's like 200
right uh technically matcha is stronger
than a cup of coffee matcha is the
strongest oh there you go
but you should feel such a small amount
but the reason why people drink matcha
is because it doesn't make you jittery
afterwards that like unsettling feeling
yeah matcha tea will not give you that
okay that's why people will replace
those
i'm all warming up are you going in the
middle of cheers you used to drink wild
turkey this is fine okay
shout out to magic hey
[Music]
okay ready go the whole thing
oh it's not bad tasting the whole god
okay that's good but honestly i'm not
kidding this this stuff like i got i
didn't finish mine i did i did it like i
did the chip challenge yeah where i kind
of took a bite
at least you didn't have to be called
out this time i know yeah it was so
funny people were like i can't believe
you didn't eat it i go finish the
[ __ ] episode finish the episode
[ __ ] i ate mine in one bite and
people were leaving that comment too
like cat didn't finish or was like i
promised you you were trying to say you
didn't yeah i was sitting right next to
it hold on let me let me do this yeah
get that three two one
20 milligrams
but yeah
i'm not i'm not kidding people people
should try this at home uh brian callan
he brings it up on fire on the kids
brian swears by it yeah he's obsessed
with it uh magicmind.com use promo code
dark 20 off uh
make us make our sponsors happy yeah
guys
we love you guys we love you so do we
have to take it every time yes we have
to it's a requirement now
[Laughter]
that i get i get terrified of everything
you know you are very nervous oh of
anything in everything right now i feel
so focused yeah we're going to be
lasered
like alert
you never drink coffee do you i do so i
do this coffee like it's like not even
that strong it's like
it's the columbra oh colombe or
something
like a lumbre you can find it in a
grocery store it's like the like like a
lumbre
is it like a blueberry
yeah i do this oat milk one the oat milk
one on the which one so the right to the
right to the right you're gone
or this one to the right keep going to
the right there right there no no to the
right there you go that one uh
[Music]
yeah oh
it's kicking up
i'm just belching i'm alert i i can hear
clear i can see clear my tastes better
the second time around are you ready are
you ready to attack your task it's also
uh uh considered the
anti-procrastination drink oh i don't
want to procrastinate anything yeah i'll
move this right here look at that
because that first organization yeah i
was going to leave it and then i was
like you know what it needs to go right
here and how do people get that focus
like you chappelle where do they go oh
well they go to magicmind.com.com
to to be as focused as i am is there a
promo code there's a promo code and it's
cats after dark yeah
first alert for his alert as i feel i
[ __ ] up that whole thing
i tried i didn't know it takes a little
while yeah yeah okay
i get dude i [ __ ] i swear i get
anxiety over like everything
it's all natural
i used to get bad weed now i'm pretty
good with it you know like i do
rogan's that person actually got me good
with weed like he was just like i know
it's random as [ __ ] but uh he took you
to the looney bin and then you're like
oh i'll be fine no
no so what happened is
i was uh he had me do he was i was doing
rogan and friends
and uh they were talking about weed and
i was like man i wish i could smoke weed
and he then he was like
why don't you
he kind of just like was like here's why
i was like i don't know it kind of
freaks me out man i was like one time i
hit this [ __ ] you know four foot bong
and it [ __ ] me up and he goes
that's why that's why you can't do weed
because you're not supposed to do it
like that yeah he goes all i want to do
he goes just get a joint take three
puffs put it down and then chill he goes
do it do it like when you have nothing
to do for for your day and that's how
i've been smoking weed this whole
[ __ ] time except for when nick brings
out that pin
what's up
yeah what was it because he was like hey
man take this spliff that's where he put
acid in it or something spliff
tobacco
a spliff is tobacco and weed in a joint
or yeah got it these that's where these
kids from rhode island just have a
different [ __ ] chappelle
look at his eyes oh my gosh
magic mine's keeping them alert that
alert you didn't kick in yet
it takes a little bit completely needs
at least 20 minutes i know
everything
is going to do this
yeah i didn't know you were throwing i
just saw him like your hand like
no
i dropped it in the bread he's like
there's also
all these lights and oh my god yeah look
at his eyes
don't bother me
that was a fun night we have a guest
here austin pollard yes sir yeah
aka
i know he just put the whole government
yeah i don't know why not say that i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding
i think everybody knows yeah i'm not
gonna lie i didn't know his last name
until just now right now he did it no
yeah i thought his last name was browse
thanks for having me guys austin brown
welcome
yeah no welcome back bro i love talking
to you bro thank you you're always a
good person to talk to hey thanks man i
like all you guys you've done
your podcast like five times
[Applause]
is he the most reoccurring guest did you
realize
that you are a champion yeah he is
yep dude i did one with cat she yeah
he hated it terrible
my favorite episode oh damn my favorite
episode we just talked about a bunch of
ladies after five
you know what because we talked a lot
about a lot like a lot of uh
like female artists yeah female artists
and stuff like that yeah and so like i
never like most people that i talk to
don't really listen to like female
artists the way i do
i'm so glad you and
i said it without if you said that in
earnest it would have came across
exactly
so either way it would have ended up the
same way you
because when i was at juilliard you know
you just really have to
commit to creating you know and i sound
like everyone i went to college with
really i went i was in the theater
department so that's literally what
everyone sounds like
yeah was you in hamilton uh no i was not
in hamilton i don't know why i said it
like that it was not magic mine got me
[ __ ] up
in a good way in a good way because i
got it to take it and it's good
chappelle is very uh susceptible to
placebo
none of us none of us are any are
feeling anything you don't notice the
positive effects it's just it's all
dreams
there's no alcohol in it
oh uh but little brows is something uh
cool that we're gonna do today uh also
important thing though note
we are not on super cast everything's
gonna be free that is a change okay that
has happened since our two weeks okay
yeah so which is good uh better so can
we talk about raunchy things at the
beginning still or do we have to wait to
the second half uh ten minutes just for
youtube monetization purposes perfect
but i don't think we have to talk about
anal every episode oh yeah
yeah
yeah
dude that might be that'd make it
i don't want to be on any episode that
we're doing that doesn't have anal talk
on it
you kids from rhode island i know
i don't know why i keep saying you can
pretend they said he's the only person i
know rhode island
pretend this happened uh
this happened right after he said that
what okay
oh wow
he's too quiet i needed my own horn for
that horn yeah yeah
so you guys been getting raunchy on this
show lately that's what's up cats
yes but
about personal matters yeah can we ask
austin now then real quick since he
wasn't here last time are we playing
with the team
they were talking about eating out right
right right is this something you you
would do you've done
you don't you don't want to do chevelle
screams it
uh
yeah yes you enjoy yeah yeah i knew i
liked you i knew i liked him that's like
i feel like that's kind of normal i
don't know i feel like it's kind of
standard now oh my god i feel like not
enough people do the other thing anymore
no one really eats [ __ ] everyone eats
ass yeah i don't know i just feel like
when i was growing up it was like kind
of normal and then it never really
seemed like a big deal just like a part
of everything that weird area where ohio
ohio's got meth too yeah yeah so because
kyle tells me some wild [ __ ] about that
yeah arizona has met arizona's like big
and bad everybody
theo did a thing it was called uh uh
state wars and
we did a bracket of all the states and
we had people sending videos why they
thought their states should win and like
everyone said they were the meth capital
of the world is there an objective
meth capital of the world or of the
united states if you had to objectively
look at statistics is there one state
that just shines above all else i feel
like i saw west virginia had the highest
opiate deaths oh sure yeah okay yeah the
midwest's like that and then i do
kansas what does it say phoenix and mesa
were the two cities with the highest
rate of methadone
mesa that's where i grew up that's where
i'm from tatted it on my stomach uh
state 48. state 48. dude yeah like super
super heavy meth but a certain part like
it's usually like
actually
yeah east mesa and west mesa where i
grew up i grew up in west mesa shout out
west mesa
uh i don't know why i did that i'm sorry
that no one does that
but
literally
a lot of meth that's like the strong
suit where was breaking bad centered
around was new mexico new mexico okay
yeah i picked but i think i think
there's something with meth
in the desert yeah you know what i mean
like there's something with it like i
think because you're like maybe like you
can just go in the middle of the desert
and cook it and not have to worry about
anyone i guess
what would be the difference if you were
in like the middle of like texas
yeah
more here they have the texas has a lot
of middle of nowhere
stuff i think they just maybe it was
cheaper to shoot it in new mexico i i
don't know i don't think there was any
one specific reason for it yeah actually
google why why do they cook meth in the
desert
i love that
right yeah yeah i want to see what they
the answer is so i'll stick it up my
only experience with meth is growing up
i always heard about people who were uh
like that i grew up around they were
either chefs or nurses who are really
into meth because they couldn't afford
to constantly do coke so they do meth
and stuff that's cheaper yeah and
they're just all these like super high
functioning professionals who are just
like i i need this to get through my job
yeah
and method's like a upper right it's
speed based it has to be right yeah so
maybe like you get that super you get
that super human strength
you know what i'm saying oh speaking of
meth i don't know if this was
the drug but i saw a post right before
we started filming this of i guess
azalea banks is arguing with julia fox
kanye west's ex-girlfriend right now
online and she had posted a photo of
julia fox like like taking hard drugs
like inserting something into herself
calling her a crackhead and i thought
that was wild yo she just posted that
online
how about that's intense slander but
also there's like a photo of it yeah how
about celebrities uh slanderers arguing
online
kanye's on one right now oh he is on one
yeah he is [ __ ] on one i think he's
going through it you think so yeah i
think he needs a lot of like emotional
support at this
moment the [ __ ]
like because
like
i feel like after his mom passed
there's so much trauma in his life yeah
i know i feel i feel bad for the dude
i'm actually like
a die hard kanye fan i like him a lot i
love everything that he you know creates
and stuff like that but yeah it is weird
to watch because it's like yeah i don't
i don't know what to [ __ ]
i don't know what to say like i don't i
honestly i don't know the guy so it's
not kind of hard for me it's like when
people go hard on demi lovato yeah it's
like i don't know her you know she's
interested
in the ghost and [ __ ] i mean i think
that's two different
situations i think demi's just
demi has a lot of
ghosts and trolls
see with
kanye feel like it actually has a mental
illness i think
this one too demi's just doing anything
to stay relevant
say one more time meatball
uh demi's just doing anything to say
relevant like connie like
yeah she like this [ __ ]
is like she used to be an addict
she was an addict she also said that she
was
sexually assaulted by one of her drug
dealers when she overdosed recently so
she has a lot of different things going
on
oh yes apologies they they have a lot of
trauma they would
that's her pronoun
no yes oh you know only notion though
that's actually a good question no is
that what you're saying no they is
actually can be an individual
and like that's their pronoun oh that's
her pronouns yes i forgot about that not
even her that's these pronouns there
brows backwards
bros you've been an addict not dead
[Laughter]
listen we've all done some [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
like everyone has their names i'm going
to spoken at his uh
uh one of the facilities are you still
at that facility no i'm not at that one
but yeah you came and spoke to the
people there
yeah i know it came off aggressive but
the magic of mine got me oh my god
mine yeah
you meant well i meant well i thought it
was fire joke that was still funny as
[ __ ] dude yeah i think uh what what i'm
saying like you understand like
well i think both of them have mental
health issues right and i like i know
demi like i know a girl that used to
like sober companion her and stuff okay
she's like i think she has mental health
issues you know yeah that's okay but it
goes through like babies
doesn't think so
i love that
but kanye like goes through because he
remember he did this on twitter when he
has like manic episodes like yeah he's a
different platform now yeah rants and
then he'll be good and now he's on
instagram doing it right
i guess he was trending more
than the super bowl when he did that he
posted that too right he posted that he
was trending more he's like this is not
what i wanted to do oh god but i think
there's degrees of mental illness i
think hers are is probably low this is
my opinion yeah a little bit lower
his is probably like higher yeah yeah
and i do feel like she does it for
attention as well
when i look at everything she's done
yeah i don't think kanye's um going into
cupcake shops and getting upset when
they don't have any sugar for you one
thing going on
know i don't know how long
and maybe brows you can you know vouch
for this too i don't know how long she's
been like sober but i know like when
you're like
freshly
you know sober trying to feel you're
trying to like find yourself
and it's so [ __ ] tough like
like
i mean the darkest days of my life was
when i was you know
after my brother died and i was drinking
that was like the darkest days and after
that like trying to like figure yourself
out it's like the toughest [ __ ]
like it take it takes a long [ __ ]
time i feel like you know where i'm at
now i feel like i have a pretty solid um
grip on who i am but like that post
of like you don't talk about like when
you're freshly like freshly
yeah you know cutting the [ __ ] oh gosh
it's [ __ ]
you're out of your [ __ ] mind yeah
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
because you're used to like doing this
thing that kind of takes it away from
takes uh
your own thoughts away from you yeah you
know you're trying to numb yourself yes
that is that you post that cat no
that's not a car driver bro oh that's a
hard picture
oh browse question do you watch euphoria
i do i i always wanted to ask somebody
who has gone through addiction their
views on that show because it's so i
think the first few episodes of every
season because it has to like to some
degree kind of be playful and have not
be so depressing right up front yeah
like it glamorizes that life and then
like the season episode five happens and
then it's like the
the real honest brutal truth of like
what it's like being an addict does it
trigger you at all watching stuff like
that for me now because i'm coming up on
like seven years sober so i'm pretty far
congratulations by the way thank you but
like so for me when i watch that stuff
now like i see it as like the art of it
like i watch it for like the story line
and the way it's shot and everything
episode five triggered me a little bit
because that's like super intense yeah
but i was just having this conversation
with someone about like if that's good
for the culture or not to like expose
that to everyone and they were like why
not like if what's the alternative like
dare and everything else like yeah and
then when it gets mentioned we just like
hide everything we're like no that
doesn't exist but that's like the real
way it is so i think it's kind of cool
that they're painting it
in that light i don't think it glorifies
it i think it just shows the reality
you know i actually
i think that's fair you know what i mean
because like when uh when we were
growing up we had like [ __ ]
full house and all that [ __ ] and they
like not everybody's home life was like
that but i think more people could
relate to some [ __ ] like
they seen around school like someone
getting [ __ ] up or someone being
addicted to some [ __ ] like yeah you see
more of that than you would like the
full house experience not saying like
you should not you should rule out you
know shows like full house yeah it's
just
you know just as much as those shows are
shown
these shows should be shown yeah because
different people have different
realities yeah everyone has a different
life everybody has different experiences
not everyone's gonna have some clean
cookie-cutter experience and not
everyone's gonna have like addiction
issues or like all this like weird how
are you guys how are you guys feeling
about what like in general
yeah i'm just feeling i feel laser
focused yeah really you'll pass that
spell i feel better than i watched we
passed the pen to him i think that's
what he wants
i'm walking over because i don't play
sports mm-hmm
to be fair you can't be as bad as nick
nick did like what like a jazz hand like
in your direction if i threw that whole
decimal yeah
well also there's so many lights that
just came out of nowhere
the way he threw it though i thought it
was going to land his lap
no it would have bounced off these thick
thighs
this was my uh out of all of kanye's
ranting
uh
this was my favorite this was in my uh
tweet screenshot uh
but uh
i've learned that using all caps makes
people feel like i'm screaming at them
i love that that he just learned that
somehow
you see the next post no he goes [ __ ]
that cap's back
he's out of it yeah he took everything
down again which is kind of upsetting
yeah it seems like he takes everything
down and he'll do like these reposts or
like these new posts of
i don't know it's just like yeah he's on
one i mean yeah i am a huge kanye fan
though like
i'm a massive
kind of i'm the same with michael
jackson he did some crazy [ __ ]
well we don't know for
i thought you were talking about
fighting neverline
that never
well not unpopular opinion kind of
controversial like a rhode island
opinion
do you think he's doing it just because
he has an album coming out like do you
think like
our stuff no yeah you don't have to he's
kanye west that's why i was asking
though because like i know like a lot of
people do like crazy [ __ ] too there's
some people that are like pr i mean he's
been so relevant regardless so like if
he pulls if he drops an album like
people are already there when he doesn't
have to really pull donda too
when's it coming out though 222. and the
netflix special just dropped yeah
i want to watch that you might be onto
something too though a little bit he's
kanye west it's different of course he
doesn't think about it though he was
quiet
during like like he didn't go on that
much of a rant until he announced that
donder 2 was coming out like he wasn't
on a manic episode or anything he was
kind of keeping to himself
and then he started to emerge like
crazier and crazier and crazier am i
just that's a fair that's unfair i'm
going to give him the benefit of the
doubt i'm going to say like he probably
is doing something like that yeah i mean
i think that's a fair statement i also
don't i mean i don't know i like i feel
like he wouldn't need to do it of course
but i think that's a fair thing to say
because you do see that a lot yeah you
know
i think you would just hope that it
isn't because it then comes at the
like expense of his family
like his relationship to the mother of
his children his children
and then like his his family her family
i think that's when it gets a little
weird and you hope it's not a pr stunt i
know but then again there's a kardash
my favorite is uh
my favorite is uh kylie no chloe kendall
kendall yeah like kendall
oh yeah she's cool that's the one the
one that models
i mean they all model
in one way or another
[Music]
ah she's bad kendall don't forget about
your boy chappelle and she's like not
like fake us ass fake again no just uh
body wise
no they've all had plastics of course
yeah but not as like crazy oh you're
talking about like the crazy kind of
booty
still
all right let's go around the room
let's go around the room and everyone
say name the who they think is the most
beautiful kardashian ugh
i don't
know them
i definitely have my preferences but i
could not tell you yeah
well he can show you right now yeah just
pull up a picture of all of them yeah
kardashian sisters but austin what
you're saying like with yeah with the
kanye's yeah saying like the caps thing
yeah
and then right after saying like [ __ ] it
caps are back yeah i think he's
ahead of what we're thinking he knows
what he's doing like he knows how to
stir the pot yes yeah he does okay very
far ahead that's that's fair i think the
way he thinks i don't know but it seems
like he tries to make statements like he
talks about how he thinks about in like
100 years so he's like he says things
where he like doesn't care if he's
likable because he's trying to make a
statement to where like that would stand
out 10 years later yeah so it's like i
mean look it up look at that uh look at
all his albums yeah all his albums they
like
they're pretty timeless
you know when you listen to a lot of his
work
it's just like of course yeah i can
listen to that forever yeah you know
what i mean like that's i think
you know that i think that's the one
thing that makes him so dope in every
album he's ever done
he's always made it with the time he's
been really good at that when i quit my
job and drove cross country in a day
uh
okay okay i listened to all five uh
con first five yeah albums consecutively
that was the road trip music yeah that
was the soundtrack too yeah it was funny
you're driving away from me you told me
that story so he's he's definitely a i
[ __ ] love kanye yeah super talented
yeah i love him
i love him i miss the old kanye
dude through the wire
that's my kanye yeah oh wow kanye is my
kanye
i like them all right i was just doing
this which snoop dogg
which snoop dogg is yeah
snoop lion
uh that's a little probably yeah that's
the only one i didn't really
think i didn't get on board with but
everything else
i love what do you guys think of the
super bowl halftime performance i wish i
was in it you know
hey
one of the quick walkers you didn't see
that no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no we saw it yeah
i thought it was dope you know i thought
it was dope yeah
they should tour they should bring back
that up and smoke tour
that they did do you ever see that dvd
of up and spoke no it's [ __ ] it's so
sick i don't know it was like
do they have everything there's a bunch
of [ __ ] like that that like uh you never
heard of smoke torching what's up you
never heard of the open smoke i've heard
of it yeah oh yeah i don't know who's in
it though who was on
dr dre
snoop dogg ice cube
um
that already sounds amazing cypress hill
was on that tour that sounds awesome um
[ __ ] who was on that tour it was massive
big [ __ ] tour but they could pull it
off again
remember when when snoop and dre did
coachella they brought out that hologram
and he thought he was actually talking
to tupac but he's talking to like a lamp
for an hour who did snoop dogg
after the hologram came out yeah uh he
said that he was small he didn't know
the hologram he didn't know the hologram
was fake and he was so high out of his
mind he thought he was hanging out with
tupac the entire night but it turns out
he was talking to like a plant whoa oh
my gosh
snoop lyon
wait wha what were you pulling up were
you pulling up something people uh oh it
was one of the things
but oh see i'm so focused
i'm so lazy i mean this isn't that great
of a picture of them but no but we know
who they are yeah
but yeah
well then yeah nick what do you think
out of all those
i'm pretty sure we all agree or
the guys agree what
you think i'll have a different answer i
think we're all veering towards the
right on this picture
the right the right i personally
probably would say kim actually really
okay kim i think if you look back at
photos of kim when she was younger
before her surgery she was so [ __ ]
she was yeah i liked her the way she
looked she's still gorgeous now wait but
if you see her
when she was younger before she's gotten
work done and you see like yeah just her
like beautiful natural features i think
she was gorgeous oh i like chris i was
going to say mommager yeah
that's the label she gave herself yeah
yeah because she imagined she's a beast
yeah uh-huh hey listen i know people
hate on that family
[ __ ] it i respect it mm-hmm i mean they
they they were able to do something and
figure out a way to capitalize on their
[ __ ] life to where they're
been relevant for [ __ ] how long now
the biggest show like the biggest
[ __ ] show the only show that was
keeping e-network [ __ ] live you know
i don't know if anyone works for
e-network here but sorry if you do but
you know what i mean though like yeah
and now they have hulu i hate when
people try to blame like when little
girls are like looking at them no no no
no teach your [ __ ] kids
t i hate when people try to [ __ ]
pinpoint as to why like something else
is a problem to why their kids suck and
it's like no you [ __ ] be a parent
starts at the home yeah it starts at
home everything [ __ ] starts at home
sorry that was aggressive magic mine
called promo code yeah
for the full experience watch this
episode after taking
one of those magic mindfulness yes for
the full effect i want to make a song
about magic mine kind of i've gotten a
bit pumped right now
yeah
magic mine we're speaking of that oh
yeah um make the announcement right here
so we're doing a contest
um the winner of the contest
gets to feature on the thick boy album
with me chen chappelle ton of other
people are on there so we're gonna have
people submit verses or courses
just a song in uh we're gonna review
them and pick a winner and you're gonna
be on the album can i can
remember i got that message from the
dude that was like y'all want to battle
little brother yep and he sent me the
video
i don't want to put him on blast i would
like to play that so it's terrible
you gotta you gotta do it have you seen
uh kevin holland the mma fighter uh he's
been uh oh uh he's a funny guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh he's been like trolls
always talking [ __ ] and then when you
fought one yeah he's done he's done it a
couple times now and it's becoming like
a thing and like it's getting huge views
but he's just [ __ ] up these trolls
he's like okay
but you can't really hurt them with rap
you can
embarrass them maybe but it still gives
them their opportunity that they were
looking for but yeah you got to a
myeloma yeah that's what you got to do
we can i'm trying to make a song with
one
positive thing
sorry that was me we'll do the verses
afterwards
because the rap is so funny wait is it
good or is it bad
it sounds like it's gonna be terrible
right terribly good terribly good also
it's terrible but it's so terrible it's
funny and good yeah terribly good i mean
yeah terribly
when he starts dancing at the end he's
like
i know i couldn't look away
what what it was so weird because he was
like
let me let me see my video but i'm
sitting here i'm like the cat's battle
is over dude like that was just like
yeah it was like a year and a half ago
uh this guy
was probably gonna want to be in the
contest
uh oh you got one uh someone sent in a
cat's uh a cat's after dark song already
uh oh [ __ ]
awesome i haven't listened oh okay so
we're all gonna be surprised by this
yeah yeah
and then i gotta show that dude's rap
please should we i don't know i don't
want to be if he actually sent it in if
he sent it in he's like giving you he
didn't put it out there he dm'd it to
you right he deemed it to me yeah
it's really not that bad it's just like
it's not bad it's just funny dancing and
stuff
all right you got it nick i i will
or else while you're doing that i'm
gonna send meatball oh i have a video i
have sound in here so i can play it but
yeah so basically send submissions
should i just my email nick yeah yeah
send submissions to lowbrowsmusic
gmail.com me and chen are going to
review some of them and then the best
ones we'll go through on this show
and pick a winner
you have to be good by the way
not good what are you looking for in the
contestant just good okay like just like
when we yeah when the show found you
mm-hmm everyone's like this guy's
[ __ ] awesome so like that that's what
we want yeah that's why i want to do it
because you guys gave me a shot uh and
so i want to pass that along it'd be
dope to have someone feature on it like
that that'd be dope like a fan come in
yeah you know and just start rapping and
spitting and [ __ ] and it doesn't be like
this [ __ ] spitting right you
know that's you know yeah magic mine
yeah
not just rappers not just rappers like
any song yes singers rappers
yeah anything okay yep cool
rap any any any like not like
instruments like if you play instruments
that's cool too but like singing or
rapping basically oh okay do you know
when the album uh target date no we
don't have a target date yet but it'll
be probably in like the next couple
months
yeah
and there's a little ton of sick
features so many features yeah it's
going to be done it's so important so
who are some of the features
um i don't know if we can say yet but
it's mostly our crew and then a couple
other uh bonuses big features yeah i did
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like
killed it bro chappelle came in there
one take timmy one thing one take timmy
literally the the producer was like yeah
we're good he just like one taked it and
that producer is usually like making
people do multiple takes did you rap on
it did you sing on it
do i look like i'm ready
that's a loaded question
what do you want to see mariah carey oh
when you whoa
i'm just kidding
that was terrible yeah magical but you
went for anyway that's not how you might
smell no no you guys are [ __ ] up for
real no how i think i feel like
yeah yeah i feel like you're just kind
of stressed about taking something new
because i know you're very nervous about
it yeah oh it's anxiety that and the
weed that's what white people talk about
when they say anxiety okay i finally
feel that i finally get it
magic mine magic mine play this dude's
video
and uh also christian sorry for uh
leaving in your password your instagram
on the edit yeah thanks for that
yeah when i do that when i bring up
something uh on king and a sting and we
send to the editor joe i give him a note
i'm like hey i logged in here had an
email here so it's a little bit on both
of us
i
usually extreme ownership but uh
either way my back
we got it out it's blurred and he
changes passwords so you did change the
password so you're good now yeah yeah
did anyone hack into your [ __ ] no
luckily uh this guy caught real quick
right yeah yeah this guy chase who
usually like makes like memes it was
like within a chase
chase
i got that done before i just woke up
and texted you too because i'd rather it
be
sorry
because i got i
got notified like two hours later
changed my password on all my major
accounts went to bed then i woke up i
was like i feel like i'm
missing some password so i told him too
because i couldn't think of it off the
top my head so i just had him edit it
out
eddie bravo one time uh
oh
your number yeah he posted a screen
record of some random video and but
it like had his that oh he he got a text
it was a group text and i was the number
that wasn't saved
and i got all these texts and and they
would text me and i'd just be like have
you ever seen the show below deck
these are the people that were texting
me and then i was like oh i have a
podcast about below deck and i was just
sending about the link to my podcast
because i got like
hey there you go 70. uh and
most people are like no i don't know
what it is like did they know it was
your number or was it they were just
texting someone random that they had saw
i think
a number of people who texted like
figured it out
with the context because it was theo
brendan a number not saved uh and then
you're also sending your own stuff to
them
you're also sending your own yeah when
they texted me i was like you're not
going to troll me i'll i'll text you
until you stop
that's great oh so what did he say so
oh so this is from
e-casius underscore 420 underscore shout
out to blaze
it's coming up he said hey chappelle i'd
like to challenge little brows to a red
bottom i don't know where to send the
video and nick didn't answer so i'm
trying to get my shot wherever i can i
hope you look at this
and this is the video he said all right
good luck with the name little ones i'm
gonna mock the ground yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that's [ __ ] that's always
late 80s i think a critique i would give
is just like you can't really
like he's like whatever yeah i can't
hear his music's so loud
like yeah it's louder than the but he
doesn't have great quality yeah
rapping just seems very like low yeah
that's the only thing but there's a
little bit of reservation i feel like
from him yeah that's what we're seeing
like if he was totally [ __ ] giving it
yeah he's like
yeah yeah he's that's biz marquee
yeah
i like yeah i like my flow so hot
forehead starting to glisten bruh that
[ __ ]
that's just laughs i was worried i
thought you guys were setting up for
like i thought it was gonna be crazy
that was dope yeah same i thought it was
gonna be like legitimately bad it's good
it's not bad i i guess it's good in its
own way we did set it up horribly yeah
right but it's just it just had
something about it there's just
something about it and like the stuff
like the words he's like
flowing as far as like yeah my flow so
hard forehead start to glisten which is
kind of like
yeah generic yeah
but he makes it like he has like his
cool swagger to it yeah all right simon
cowell i'll whip you i'll whip you up
i'll pull you out and whip you out like
a gem towel yeah like a gym towel would
be like just get that gentile to it and
then he got the little see i i would
have to listen to it again before like
all the lyrics yeah oh i've listened to
like 80 [ __ ] times
that's why you know the
420 whatever does he know that you're a
fan of that video
did you respond to him oh [ __ ]
i never did
i just oh [ __ ] cuz like he may not know
that you guys are like huge fans of this
video oh we texted we texted
all this time he's probably bummed like
damn nobody opened my video i know damn
i never responded meanwhile you know the
lyrics
[Music]
so listen i got much time to describe
what i gotta prescribe my patients i see
you standing right there and yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
reminds me of j5 a little bit he's like
say ho if you know that my flow get you
out on the floor
yeah it's all like it's all just like
this is like the smallest simplest words
but so since i feel bad that we did not
answer his
message and we could edit this part out
if we want but i figured i'd just like
give him a video
shout out right now saying thank you for
sending that video out that's a lot of
difference
sure that's a lot of courage so shout
out to that guy
how you doing
jesus christ well you said it takes a
lot of courage it feels like you're
calling like a fat actress
no cats we love your [ __ ] man thank you
for sending that in it was very brave
it was interesting bro
that [ __ ] was hot i know my forehead
starts yeah it flows so hot my forehead
is starting to glisten bro that [ __ ] is
fine and that break that break
game game
catch chappelle on cameo at
it's just chappelle taking the magic
minds and doing his characters
he knocks at like 20 in 10 minutes oh
sorry now i'm coming down dude i'm
feeling this take another one
this is brand recognition
because you guys helped me understand
that i'm probably just having a panic
attack
so
yeah you're good now i remember the
first time you had a panic attack from
drinking like three sips of coffee
during a podcast
you're just looking at me like is this
normal i'm like you're going to be fine
coffee place stay straight up
commissary coffee yeah they so their two
shots
is four shots
and i'm like don't don't call it two
you don't even call it four
yeah shot is a double because i'm like
yo give me a small size of this [ __ ]
they're like yo how many shots coming in
two and then all of a sudden i find out
yeah our two shot is basically four i go
hey say that to me you know what i mean
cause i was freaking out on the podcast
my teeth were chattering it was like i
did cocaine or something what's up
meatball
do you know what it feels like to take
cooking huh i'm taking cocaine i did it
i did it uh oh
i did it when i was like 19 and i hated
every moment of it what really did you
have i don't like this [ __ ] i don't
like this upper feeling did you feel
euphoria though who did you feel
euphoria sorry
oh sorry did you feel you fork
was there like a happy stage for a
little while no i didn't like it okay
and i was trying to like drink more so i
could like try to come down
or whatever i remember yeah it was
stupid i was like i'll never do that
again all this [ __ ] dripping in the back
of my throat you might have had some bad
cocaine too though i mean it was a lot
of it's cut with stuff so i had friends
with meth in arizona have you done coke
i think i was on math yeah
huh huh nothing never mind what's that
has chin done cocaine bro he just had a
whole conversation with me about it i
wasn't there for that no just oh yeah
but he said i didn't know if he's done
me personally just someone i know
that looks like me that looks like me
that looks like you that's heavy his
name is ben he's been amazing
yeah been
so does he is he officially entered in
the competition or does he have to
resubmit a new entry i think that could
be yeah we reviewed it
that was cool
and i'm looking
for i want basically like i want the
person to make a song with me and chin
like i want to feature them on it so
like it doesn't have to be a rap battle
thing you know like you don't get it
yeah you don't have to do that you don't
want to roast me yeah
try to get on just do like a original
something original yeah something cool
uh wait did you did you guys have a
video
uh
there's so we asked for a bunch of
submissions next time i have to get you
logged into the cats after dark gmail
but uh one of the things
there is a song but i had to request
access but we did say like submit logos
if you want and uh we got a couple
really dope ones and i just want to like
every once in a while we'll do like a
like a
logo battle essentially we'll we'll put
yeah yeah
we don't really have a logo we do
actually ruben ruben made one um we're
gonna put his logo up against a
submission logo and we're gonna put a
vote out and it whichever one wins will
be the new logo dude it's gonna be hard
to beat ruben though i don't know
he's a killer yeah it was money what he
put out he completely captured it he's
amazing and yeah this is
he's so good at it that's fine
but this is this is the new one this is
the challenger that's the challenger
okay
that's pretty wait this is kind of fire
did i see reuben's uh it's like it was
on the
promo on that teaser yeah can you bring
that up yeah honestly i like that one a
lot i do too cool with like the lights
like being like
yeah like
that'd be sick
he
wouldn't say unfair advantage but a
little advantage over uh ruben because
he like based it off of seeing the first
episode and like we had uh oh you and i
both had whiskey glasses and that's why
you put that in there
um
i don't know
[Music]
so we're gonna
[Music]
an editor i pay uh brian from wisconsin
who who's the man like i love holly
cross i love the edit but he like used
the wrong song oh it's fine it looks
good i [ __ ] paid for it
i i paid
i don't think he goes no i'm not okay
[Laughter]
dude thank you like we were born
no i'm just kidding yeah no just like
the the [ __ ] with the homies in the
podcast world and [ __ ] it's crazy it's
really really crazy how it all happened
chick-fil-a parking lots yeah and then
nights yeah
the all the one right off the freeway
yeah you know
yep you know seriously yeah come on yeah
i've been i've been ai i've been a
chick-fil-a quite a few times right
but you're vegan now right 99.9 percent
so again what's the point one yeah what
is the point point one oh [ __ ] whenever
chick-fil-a i just feel it you know i
just
sometimes i'll get some candies
do the consistency of chick-fil-a is
insane
it's so good i don't think i don't think
i've gone there and like been like oh
that was terrible
no they [ __ ] up today no
always on point always on point
you know
yeah like
who else is really consistent
i've never had bad orange chicken from
panda
like i've never had a bad battery
if it's sitting around a little longer
it's not as good but it's still great
but it's still great it is well set
amazing it's not as amazing as a fresh
one yeah but it's still great i i will
uber eats just a large
no no no rice anything just a large
orange chicken or chicken [ __ ]
from panda cost like 20 30 bucks
i don't want to drive but you're like
[ __ ] it i got a really good honey walnut
shrimp
oh yeah you can't eat that yeah
yeah yeah have you ever seen jollibee
before
oh no i've passed by recently jollibee
has the best spicy fried chicken so it's
like so it's my favorite it's filipino
food
really yeah so like you go there and you
have like filipino spaghetti which is
like sweet spaghetti yes and then uh you
have banzai and then there is a aloha
burger i just love their spicy chicken
because they have this powder and the
seasoning on it that's so [ __ ] good
really i don't know what it is asians
and their fried chicken are also like on
one point yes dude
yeah kyoto
how do i say it i forgot remember i i
think i tried to correct you but then
you were right so i don't know
yeah yeah
oh
you'd also love banchon chicken if you
like that type of style yeah bon trend
is really good i i mean
i don't eat that much meat anymore like
i said one percent but uh
you know you know what i really [ __ ]
with and i can't get over is agassi
up on uh
yes we did yeah with my ex-boyfriend
yeah a long time ago
did you say one percent of your diet is
meat
yeah i say one percent
it's a thick hefty one percent though
right yeah no i honestly like it
especially the big one i really eat meat
like once every [ __ ] two weeks or
something
yeah that's solid that's cool yeah yeah
what's your go-to meat meal now if
you're not vegan
like do you have like one special thing
you go to chick-fil-a chick-fil-a yeah
chicken chicken chicken yeah
yeah i'm not big you know i i was trying
the steak i remember when i was trying
to cook that barbecue and i was supposed
to do a barbecue sauce and [ __ ] then i
just started getting real fat and i was
like what the [ __ ] am i doing like it
was so terrible i was like everyone was
like where's the sauce where's the sauce
like [ __ ] i'm fat
like i can't [ __ ] do it like what do
you
yeah like i see why most barbecue
[ __ ] are fat this is just like
you just [ __ ] not and shout out to
fat all the way it might be kind of hard
if you came out with a vegan sauce
though
oh my god i mean yeah
but for for not for barbecue
but see like i don't i don't do the
vegan [ __ ] cause it's like i want to
save the world i do it because it's like
i [ __ ] it makes me feel good yeah
like i think i've had the most energy i
think i've ever had in my life from
eating predominantly uh vegan diet waka
flocka said the same thing when he
converted over to uh being vegan oh yeah
forget it he said that he well one he's
a very large man like he's very tall but
he was also very chubby for his size and
his stature he said that he didn't have
a lot of energy in the moment he
switched over he just felt like this
rejuvenation
where he could perform so much better
you know and a lot like uh more so
recent than within the recent years the
vegan vegan lifestyles uh
becoming heavy in the black community
there's so many like of these like old
school rappers that have like gone vegan
yeah vegan is kind of hip-hop now yeah
it is it really is yeah yeah
a lot of it's because like you i mean
obviously you know in the [ __ ] black
community salt [ __ ] us up you know what
i mean [ __ ] up that heart heart disease
all that [ __ ] so like
you know i think just moving over to a
vegan diet it's just like helped a lot
of you know it told my dad so much he
lost like [ __ ]
i think he lost like 50 pounds oh that's
amazing yeah
he looked at a doctor he had he had some
health scare um they they said hey you
could try the vegan diet or you could
eat this way he went with the the vegan
diet and uh he's just like
you know
yeah he goes man i [ __ ] like i'm in my
early 20s i'm like all right
yeah right yeah i was like you got to
tell me that
man i'm killing the dog i'm killing that
[ __ ] man shout out to vegan life i'm
like bro you you did 17 years in prison
chill
it's just like [ __ ]
i love that your response was bad yeah
but i don't think that was the most
appropriate yes man
wait
i thought you had some something for us
oh this is the this is our current logo
uh the other one to vote this was like
the worst reveal of both of these ever
like i i went challenger first and then
there was 10 minute gap and they showed
the
it's fine we're still working out the
kings
people
realize we're just rolling with the
punches oh it's amazing i was a little
nervous about the first one and the
response was overwhelmingly positive i
know oh which can be so nice
isn't always the case i was i was pretty
i was pretty stoked yeah how nice people
were we can actually read some of the
funny comments that we got in the last
two hours oh yeah that's what we had
[Laughter]
what does it really do
well chappelle's been crediting it for
like the good stuff and the bad stuff
like half and half right now have you
heard of langhorne slim no instead of a
rapper i know that was about that
he's like a folk dude out of nashville
oh that's the funny thing to you
do we got
we got a lot of these langhorne slim
i will say wait so that's that's the
that's the one you of course you would
use that one
um is darker than the background i mean
other than all pot like i was told to
get the funniest comments every other
comment you're listening i don't like
your reasoning
that came off your dad likes his humor
i don't know if i like his [ __ ]
viewers
your father talked to them though
no there's a lot of them with that i'm
not gonna lie of course 7 out of ten
we talked about it earlier we fixed it
hopefully yeah we have different
lighting today that's why that's why i
thought like most of the comments were
very very positive there weren't that
many jokes legit the only jokes that
were there were either
some about uh like some about everyone
but the majority was like about how dark
you looked in the background in the
lighting so
about you see this yeah i look great you
look beautiful yeah
beautiful shot i remember a year ago i
made fun of nick for say uh for like
something similar where like chappelle
didn't show up great i looked kind of
odd in the uh in the video and i told
him he didn't know how to like people of
color and then the next episode it was
like a cinematic
a difference
don't tell me i can't light people up
you like alerted me of something and
then i i'm grateful i got better at it
uh
i thought this was kind of funny yeah
these both look good you might be you're
a little bright yeah yeah yeah but yeah
this final workout i thought this was a
funny comment i've got better color
correcting too yeah all right uh nick
and christian should just knuckle up
already want to see it
that was kind of funny dang that's
actually a good fight i think
yes that's a good fight i hear some help
but can't see him at all smiling
eat a dick meatball you chose the top
funniest guy these were the only funny
comments all right hey you guys asked me
i feel like christian bullies chappelle
more than chappellville always christian
a love
a love i love that chappelle lays into
meatball he's a child-sized man with
some attitude
dude i mean bro was meatball's chance to
just like i know
the the comments were not great
i'm not gonna lie
chin still don't say [ __ ] and rip job
over talks who's room job
job well that's like a mean insult what
does that mean though
no that's not an interesting job no no
no no that's not what they were saying
they were saying chin was oddly quiet
during the rim jobs talk i think is what
they were trying to get out and rim jobs
yeah
no hold on still don't say [ __ ] i think
you're reading it wrong i don't know
what's going on here meatball we gotta
find someone else to make this
right you [ __ ] to be fair he's trying
his best dude he's trying to their
comments were not good like these were
the best don't be defensive it's okay
no go go to the other one what did they
say this is the type of [ __ ] i love
chapelle
that's why you did this
meatball gotta chill chappelle gonna
relapse
that's funny that's a good one okay okay
[Music]
them we we love each other
uh theo has a special
great
wait
guys a special guest would be great if
you can contact him yeah thanks clay
nick looks like a
werewolf that's not bad at all
i got uh what are the i got i got sharp
ass canines
uh
these teeth oh yeah oh yeah dude
dude
that was such a moment
i don't know i can't that camera's not
great i'm sitting on the couch
i have sharp ass canines too oh my god
not like anyone has ever seen look so
let me see yours
when he did it was like a commercial
like a true blood [ __ ]
it was like they pulled us in it wasn't
it was great it was your moment
all
right
way too much yeah so that was fire that
was fire that was a good one the problem
is uh
christian i told you uh 10 from both
episodes you 10 10 from each episode so
we're reaching a little bit if we just
do top five like that would have been
money not your fault
i'm just going to the better ones no no
show them all [ __ ] yeah
i mean they're not great
[ __ ] it we'll figure it out don't be
self-conscious we're giving you a hard
time chappelle's black potentially
what
i don't know what that means i think you
could read someone could read that
better and potentially make it funny all
right
spells black potentially
because it's funny because you know i
don't know their tone can can cat and
chappelle go back and forth reading them
yeah yeah you read the next one 58
brendan 46 you the math skills on
meatball kid are led on this meatball
kid are legendary
yeah so the math doesn't add up but it's
all good right yeah it's all good
because nick nick's voice does not fit
his appearance also had that number of
times really really i think it was
really an insult i don't know yeah i i
didn't think it was that funny i thought
it was interesting but you don't know
licked
i never even really got that reference i
didn't look that was never seen the
cheshire cat from alice in wonderland
listen i've never seen alice in
wonderland but i know this [ __ ] cat
why have you got that because i've
gotten it before bro that's actually a
pretty good one
pull that card up yeah and then uh can
we also you do have a similar like and
the color scheme the purple oh yeah
it's crazy that's funny
why because he's wearing purple and
yellow oh
i've gotten that so many times why
though other than that look at it look
at the [ __ ] me with a smile
just put a gap right in the middle there
it's perfect he got crooked teeth anyway
or his teeth are all centered no their
teeth are amazing on that cat
no they're they're not centered they're
not centered yet for sure needs pointier
canines yeah why does that have human
teeth
i love theo's sex change
oh i just barely got it right now
why does christian always look like he
just didn't have a ball it is in his own
because maybe he just did no i
definitely did
and i did magic mine so i'm totally in
the zone so those were the top comments
yeah but now that we have like brought
it up now it's going to be like a
competition and people know
you know the funniest
and it just made me crack up
when someone compared you to looking
like the caveman for the oh from the
geico commercial
which is like
that's what i'm saying earlier actually
i've heard uh caveman more than
werewolves yeah yeah yeah i've got guy
cocaine man up yeah it's [ __ ] stupid
because i love those commercials
i love geico commercials i feel like
we've had this discussion but it was
probably on patreon only 15. all right
yeah
can you look up the title yeah pull up
pull up that geico caveman
[Music]
so easy a caveman can do it he's like
not cool
yeah
can you youtube tiny house commercial he
was like i'll have the roast stuck with
the mango salsa
i remember that one
that guy
make making bank and then they had a tv
show for like three seconds they had a
tv show yeah that one oh yeah yeah yeah
they had all it was on nbc the marriage
was built to last you're so awesome
but the house was built too small
this is kind of awesome
how long are we here for one year sparks
will thrive this is not awesome i just
want to make an omelette
the drama will be real but it won't save
you any money on car insurance
geico
would you be in my budget you called
guys this day we go i just want to make
it up
i [ __ ] love that is that like the
early
yeah
why don't they make commercials like
that anymore that was great was anyone
else disappointed by the one thing i did
want to say and i'm so glad i remembered
i almost forgot i would have been pissed
but i want to take in uh fan mail
uh
so but to do send in the family you have
to do a handwritten letter whoa okay and
we're gonna we'll read we're gonna get
old school yeah we're gonna read
people's hand written letters uh yeah
and uh send it to our p.o box it'll be
in the description
uh
yeah yeah we're gonna get some zodiac
killer letters coming in now
uh
yeah i would love for this to be like a
dope like uh
fan interaction yeah you're gonna [ __ ]
with us
yeah we should i like fan interaction
we'll be zooming people and [ __ ] yeah uh
we gotta talk a day before and just
throw out ideas real quick
yeah yeah yeah we'll do that we'll do
that for sure
um do you want me to sign it off do you
want to sign it up uh no no no no yeah i
don't know how to take just take the
rage say [ __ ] jesus take the wheel
that's all i did i thought i knew more
of that stuff
and maybe hit that hit that contest
browse hat oh this is how this is how
this is how we wrap shows this is how we
do
everybody get the plugs in
nobody knows
that i got another package
i'll be on the road
um
february 25th and 26th i'll be in kansas
city
the comedy club of kansas city
and then uh
after that march
10th
through 12th
i'll be in uh
[ __ ] springfield missouri and blue
room comedy club then
where am i after that come on meatballs
pull up my website you got it there he
goes uh
scroll down hey scroll scroll down you
ever seen bert kreicher uh just rattle
off his dates like remember his
memorization he'll just like do like 30
i'm like he'll say the date in the city
date and city he remembers it all though
yeah he does it like a promo for like a
and it works [ __ ] millions of people
listen i gotta get better better at
promo [ __ ] i gotta get better at all
this stuff i want people to come to my
shows i don't know what more to say
other than that but just please buy a
ticket you're getting better at him i'm
getting better at him but you know it's
hard it's hard to [ __ ] sell tickets
it is [ __ ] hard even being on three
podcasts it's still hard to sell tickets
uh but yeah so uh and i didn't mean that
it was like you know pray for me type of
[ __ ] i just mean like i'm just telling
you guys it's [ __ ] hard okay
and then where else would i be oh yeah i
said uh oh april 8th and april 9th salt
lake salt lake city wise guys comedy
club and then i'm doing a one-nighter
may 12th and and phoenix had stand up
live tell the cat cats after dark fans
if you come like okay you gotta [ __ ]
yeah dab them up if you're coming
up
although i do like at the end of every
every show
uh every you know show i do i do meet
everybody
you know anybody that wants to come up
and meet me not like not like i'm
forcing people to come up and beat me
and [ __ ] that'd be funny but uh no i do
you make them wait in the line and i'm
always like out there selling my merch
and all that stuff so hell yeah yeah
yeah uh big boy album if you guys wanna
if anyone wants to be on it submit a
verse or a chorus or a song and me and
chen are going to review them and we
bring them on here and we'll all pick
the winner should we have the fans like
vote on the winner once we get to that
point maybe
kind of how you're comparing like the
how
it's your album yeah
i think uh
i think we'll whittle some down and then
yeah was that
jesus
uh yeah we'll whittle them down we'll
bring the best ones on this show and
then we'll pick the winner yeah dope so
it could be like fan pics or all of us
here pick or something like that i think
when we did the cats rap battle we just
i think it was us that just kept it yeah
right so
definitely has to be the best one i
think yeah if we fan voted
oh we would do like the so we voted and
then we would do the uh
yeah i think we all gave our opinion and
then we had a poll yeah yeah yes
i forgot i don't know that was awesome
though yeah we think we could have kept
going the best yeah that's it yeah
that's it
oh all right i'm going fishing
so if you guys have any lures you can
send me i'm just kidding just my uh
chinsuyi youtube
that's it nick
uh another podcast network youtube
uh c payload uh see paleo6 on instagram
that's about it
okay yeah yeah
hey let's get [ __ ] christian up to
ten thousand followers yeah can we do
that
right monetize what did you say i said
don't get us d monitor yeah this is not
on uh super cast anymore so yeah we
can't do that wait so if i promote that
i want to get him ten thousand followers
and that's fine
i'm almost there almost there yeah
promoting christian's uh instagram will
get a shadow band on youtube
very
likely all right dope all right bye
awesome
[Music]
jesus take the wheel yeah
[Music]
you